here come the bucks the other way alive
steps up another three
fener kubo the offensive rebound putback
is good and the foul
what do you want them to do that's a
non-shooting foul
gets to the rim on a pretty slick pass
but that's to me
how he can get easier quality shots
but this is just good decision-making by
giannis quick pick and roll
gets crowder off his body gets some
momentum to the rim
and finishes and your in huddle
coaching and encouragement has garnered
so much praise from your peers in recent
days
what do you say to devin booker lopez
way short on the three tucker grabs it
back to antenna
and the bucks regain the lead
great extra epic play pursuing the
basketball
question is did that left foot step out
of bounds but i know it's a heck of a
play
finding giannis for the finish
getting minutes because of the injury
dario charge hasn't played a heck of a
lot
and tenecupo draws the foul thanks and
all but a chance for a three-point play
[Applause]
one-on-one with crowder that's two
strong dudes down low
to tenecupo banks at home
jonathan's gonna come in now for lopez
holiday inside pass broken up by booker
still loose
antenna
[Applause]
a minute remaining here in this third
period
antenna kubo throws it up shot won't go
gets the rebound back
up banks it in and a foul
[Applause]
punishing the sons here in the third
taking advantage of the size and
strength
gets the match up he likes misses a shot
but continues
to attack the offensive boards this just
in only seven turnovers from milwaukee
madison season opening finds a ton of
coupon for another flush
three for 14 from the field
on the alley back to back
40-point final games by youtube tv
giannis with another magnificent
performance
40-10 shaquille o'neal had back-to-back
40 and 10's back in 2000 lebron james in
his championship season as well in
our senior hall tomorrow a standing
ovation
for the beloved giannis athena kupo here
in milwaukee
[Applause]
back-to-back 40-point games only six
players
have scored 40 or more in back-to-back
finals games
we told you about lebron james shaquille
o'neal michael jordan did it many times
jerry west and rick barry what company
in his first nba finals
t gets inside bank shot misses